european citizenship  is one of the most significant  achievements of the urban project  the rights that are guaranteed by  european citizenship  are unique in the world since the united  kingdom left the european union  millions of european citizens living in  the uk  have applied for settled statues to  secure  their eu rights there but many  have not yet applied if you have aeo  citizen family members or friends  in the uk please ask them  if they applied the deadline to apply  ends on 30th of june 2021.  the eu delegation to the uk and the  commission services for justice  in cooperation with the embassies in the  uk  have been providing support and  information  to au citizens on how to apply for  settled status in line with the  withdrawal agreement  we at the open commission will continue  to support the protection of the rights  of  eu citizens in the uk